GUILLAUME LAFORGE:
Hello, everyone,
and welcome to this session
about the new Java 11
runtime for Cloud functions.
Java is a very important
and widely used
programming language
in the enterprise.
And customers have
asked for Java support
ever since we released the
first runtime for Google Cloud
Functions.
So let's dive into Java
11 for Cloud functions.
And that's my pleasure
to introduce you
to my colleague Eamonn.
EAMONN MCMANUS: Hi,
I'm Eamonn McManus.
I'm the lead developer
for GCF Java.
GUILLAUME LAFORGE: And
I'm Guillaume Laforge.
I'm a Developer Advocate
for Google Cloud.
And I'm focusing on our
serverless solutions.
I also contributed to the
Java API for this runtime.
So I'm very excited to
share that with you.
So let's start with a few words
about the serverless concept.
More than just a
buzzword, serverless
is both about an operational
and a programming perspective.
From an operational
standpoint, developers
can focus on their
code, and don't
need to bother about servers to
manage, clusters to provision.
It's a pay for usage model.
So you pay proportionately
to the number
of times your functions are
invoked or the duration.
So you really pay only for
the underlying infrastructure
when it's actually used for your
workloads, not when it's idle.
For the programming
model, developers
are encouraged to write more
granular services instead
of the good old big monolith.
And functions react to events,
so whether it's an http call
or it's some event coming from
your Cloud infrastructure.
Furthermore, we've been
building Cloud Functions
with an open approach.
So we'll tell you more about
this with the Functions
framework.
And you can easily run
your functions elsewhere,
not just in the Cloud, but also
on your local machine, which
improves the developer
experience, as well as anywhere
else, on premises, or even
in other clouds, potentially.
So Google Cloud offers three
serverless compute solutions.
So there's Cloud
Functions, which
is the topic of the day, where
you write event-driven services
a small unit of code.
There's App Engine
for deploying your web
application, your services,
your backend APIs,
like mobile backends.
And there's Cloud Run, where
you can deploy anything
within a container
with any language
that you want any runtime, any
executable you want to use.
Now, zooming back on
to Cloud Functions,
there were so far only
three runtimes available.
So there's node
js, Python, and Go.
And today, we're also happy
to have Java 11, which
is available in beta.
Let's now have a look at the
types and shape of functions.
And I'll let Eamonn tell you
all about our Java function API.
EAMONN MCMANUS:
Thanks, Guillaume.
So there's basically
two kinds of functions.
And this is true for all
of the different language
runtimes on GCF.
There are http functions
and background functions.
So http functions react
to a URL being accessed.
So it's a public URL
subject to access controls.
And whenever there's an http
request made to that URL,
the function gets executed.
And it can specify what the
reply to the http request
is going to be.
And then there's
background functions.
And those are invoked by
the system in response
to certain events.
And so we see here some of
the events that that might be.
For example, Pub/Sub
events or a file
gets created in Cloud
storage, and so on.
So, Java doesn't really have
a notion of functions as such.
So the approach that we
chose was a familiar one
for Java, which is to
define an interface that
has a single method.
And then your function
is an implementation
of that interface.
So it has that method in it.
So when we look
at http functions,
the interface in question
is called http function.
Typically, you would
just type something
like, in your IDE class example,
implements http function.
And then you would ask,
basically get the IDE
to fill in the details.
It knows that that interface
has one method so it
provides that method for you.
You don't have to remember
the method signature.
And then all you need to do
is implement that method.
And it's unsurprising.
There is a request
parameter that
allows you to see the details
of the incoming http request,
like what the URL was, the query
parameters, if there's a body
and what that was.
And then there's a
response parameter
that allows you to say what
the http response is going
to look like, status code, the
content type, the body of that,
and so on.
GUILLAUME LAFORGE:
Let's have a look
at a slightly more complex
function, an http function.
So I'm defining a new
class in a package.
I'm importing the key
functions framework
APIs, the http function
interface, the http request
and response.
And in this example, we're going
to check whether a number is
prime or not.
So we're going to use a
[INAUDIBLE] dependency.
Here, we're going to use apache
commons math, particularly
the prime's class, which
gives us the ability to know
if a number is prime or not.
So, let's implement the
http function interface
and overwrite the
service method.
The service method takes an http
request and an http response.
Here you can see on
the response object.
I can, for example, set
the status code 200,
set the content type.
Here, it's just some plain text.
And I can also get the writer
to write on the output.
On the request, on
the request object,
I can call get first
query parameter
to get the query parameters.
In this case, that's the number
that is passed as a parameter.
If there's no number, you
don't necessarily know.
So this method actually
returns an optional.
So if there's a number
that is present,
then I can have some logic.
And otherwise, I'm going to say,
OK, please provide a number.
So if a number is provided, I'm
going to look at this number.
It's actually a string.
It's part of the query string.
So I'm going to turn that string
into an integer in the end
value variable.
And then I'm going to say, OK,
is this value a prime number?
And then I call the dependency
from the primes class.
Primes is prime with the values.
It's going to return a Boolean
value, whether it's prime
or not.
And if there was a parsing
error from the query string,
I'm going to write, please
provide a valid number.
And let's have a look
at the [INAUDIBLE]..
Here I'm building with Maven.
So I'm saying, OK,
I'm using Java 11.
And here, you can see
the two dependencies.
The dependency on the
function's framework
API with the provided scope,
because the environment
on the Cloud Functions
runtime provides this API.
And I have my user dependency
on apache commons math.
And now let's have a
look at how to run this.
So please provide a number.
If I don't provide any number.
So let's add a number here.
ABC.
Oh.
Please provide valid number.
So let's do it again,
but with 1, 2, 3, 4.
So is this number prime?
It's false.
So let's say, let's try
it with another number.
17.
Is 17 prime?
Yes, that's true.
So here's our first
http function.
EAMONN MCMANUS: So we
saw http functions.
What about background functions?
The way the background
functions work behind the scenes
is that you still
have incoming http,
but you don't have to be
concerned with it anymore.
So the http has a payload,
which is a JSON payload.
And we can consider
that comes in two parts.
There is essentially
an envelope,
which is the things that are
common to all kinds of events.
And that says what the event
type is, what the timestamp is,
and so on.
And then there's
the content, which
is the things that are specific
to the particular event
that you're receiving.
Then there are two
ways of handling these.
They're quite similar.
They just have to do with how
the JSON is presented to you.
So in both cases, the envelope
will be parsed for you.
You don't have to see how
that's represented in JSON.
That's the second parameter
to these functions.
The first parameter, then,
is where they differ.
In the background function case,
the interface call background
function, that parameter will be
deserialized into a Java class
that you provide using
the JSON framework.
So that makes it a
little more convenient
to get out the
contents of the JSON.
And then in the
second form, we just
give you a string, which
is the incoming JSON as is.
And then you can parse that,
using whatever framework
you like, Jackson or whatever.
So we've seen how
to write functions.
Now, Guillaume will talk about
how you build and deploy them.
GUILLAUME LAFORGE: So let's
see how we can do that.
There are a couple of options
for building functions.
Your functions can
be built in the Cloud
from sources using Maven
or Gradle build tools.
Your sources should provide a
pom.xml file or build.gradle
project file.
You can also build a JAR with
any build tool that you want.
Either a shaded JAR
with dependencies
within the JAR file.
Or JAR archive whose manifest
descriptor provides class path
attribute pointing at
the JAR dependencies
in some local subdirectory.
With Maven, to build a
JAR project containing
your functions,
your pom.xml project
build file must import the
function's framework API
dependency.
This is actually a
dependency, which
is available on Maven
Central or [INAUDIBLE]..
It's a JAR that provides
various interfaces we've
seen representing functions,
requests, responses, context,
et cetera.
If you want to build with
Gradle, similarly to Maven,
you need to have a build.gradle
file with a function's
framework API
dependency as well.
So here, the dependency
is played over two lines,
but it's really just
for readability purpose.
And that's all.
When you deploy this
project on Cloud Functions,
the platform will take
care of the build for you.
You can then deploy
your functions
from either the Google
Cloud console UI,
from the G Cloud command line,
or with the Maven function
plug-in.
We provide a dedicated
plug-in for that.
In the G Cloud command here,
notice the Java 11 runtime
flag, which proves that we're
indeed using this new runtime.
Also note the entry point.
It corresponds to the
fully qualified class
name of your Java function.
Now that we've seen what
functions look like,
I'll let Eamonn tell you more
about the developer experience.
EAMONN MCMANUS: So,
in common with all
of the other runtimes
on GCF, we have a notion
of a functions framework.
And that is basically that the
code that we-- the framework
that we use to run your function
when you deploy it to GCF
is also available as an open
source project on GitHub.
You can download
that and build it,
and you can run your function,
of course, by deploying it.
But you can also run it
locally on your machine
using this functions framework.
So and you can also use
that to package the function
into a container and
deploy that container
wherever you like to execute
the function wherever you like.
So what this looks like
in Maven, for example,
is that in your
pom.xml, we supply you
with a plug-in that makes
this a little bit easier that
is based on top of the
function's framework.
If you put this extract
of code into your pom.xml,
then you can just type
on the command line,
maven function code on run.
We already saw this
plug-in in action
to deploy the function with
maven function code and deploy.
Here you can use maven
function code on run.
And then you can interact
with your function,
which again, is just http.
You can interact with it, you
know, either from your browser
or from the command line
using curl or from tests
or whatever you like.
GUILLAUME LAFORGE:
Let's come back
to our prime number
function, which
allowed us to know whether
a number was prime or not.
I define the build file for
Maven, the pom.xml file.
And there's a step that I
skipped, I didn't explain.
That's this part.
So this is where we are
actually configuring
the function maven plug-in, OK?
We're defining a parameter
for this plug-in.
say, the function target.
That's the function we want
to run with the function maven
plug-in.
That's this prime
number function
from my com xfm package.
And if I go into the terminal
and run MVN function run,
it's going to run my function
locally on my machine.
And it's already
running locally.
And I can, again, for example,
I can do curl request locally.
Here, 19 is a prime number.
1, 2, 3, 4 is not
a prime number, OK?
So it's very simple.
Just define the maven function
plug-in configuration here
in your pom.xml file.
And you're able to read
your function locally
in your terminal on your
laptop, on your desktop,
without having to
deploy in the Cloud.
Actually, we've been
talking about Java so far.
But you're not limited to
just the Java language.
You can also run and use
alternative JVM languages
for authoring your functions.
For instance, you can use Apache
Groovy, Kotlin, [INAUDIBLE]
or [INAUDIBLE].
Thanks to Java, thanks to
its Java virtual machine,
Java is actually
a platform where
you can run alternative
languages as well.
And you can do that with Cloud
Functions for Java as well.
So let's take an example.
Here is an http function
example using the Apache Groovy
programming language.
It looks pretty similar to
our Java example from earlier.
Same approach-- just implement
the http function interface
and use the http request,
the http response parameters,
to inspect incoming
request and reply back
to the calling client.
That's also the same approach
with background functions.
When you implement the
background function
or the raw background
function interfaces.
So let's see a concrete
example with a demo.
Let's have a look at
a Groovy function.
It's a useful
function this time,
not a hello world,
which is going
to parse a file using the Ascii
doctor format, the file that
is hosted on GitHub, and
which lists the official Java
champions.
So it's a table
with different lines
and showing the pictures,
details, names, et cetera,
town, country.
This file is using
the Ascii doctor
format, which is format--
text format--
similar to mark down.
Each row for each champion
looks something like this.
You've got some links.
You've got, again,
country, year, et cetera.
And the goal of my function
is to output something that
is easier to parse for tools.
And I'm going to output
JSON list of documents.
So I want to transform
that into this, basically.
So let's have a
look at the code.
So here's my Groovy function.
I'm implementing the http
function interface, as usual.
I have a service method with a
request and a response object.
I'm doing things like adding
a header for cache control,
setting the content type.
And then I'm going to
output some JSON data.
I also have a look at the path,
because I can sort my Java
champions by year, by country.
And what's interesting as
well-- look at this and that,
same thing below.
We're using the
Groovy equivalent
of Java lambda expressions.
That's Groovy closures.
So here, we are grouping
by date, sorting by key.
That's the name, the country,
and again, the key here.
So this is Groovy
notation, basically, right?
And what else?
Easily, I can fetch the document
that I'm going to parse.
And then I'm using the
Ascii doctor j library
to parse the document.
And I go through the
various blocks of text
to create champions,
instances of champions,
which have a name, Twitter
alias, town, country,
et cetera.
So how do I do that?
So let's have a look
at my pom.xml file.
This time, I add a
new plug-in, that's
the G Maven plus plug-in, which
is used to compile Groovy code.
You have to instruct
your Maven build to say,
OK, you also want to compile
some Groovy code along
with Java code potentially.
So that's the first plug-in.
The other plug-in, that's the
Google Cloud Functions Maven
plug-in.
And I'm saying, OK, this
is the function to run,
if I want to run the
function locally.
Let's have a look at
the dependencies now.
Still, the functions
framework API,
which is a provided dependency.
But, since I'm using
the Groovy language,
I'm adding the
Groovy library here.
And I also add the
Ascii doctor j library
for parsing the document.
What's interesting
with this function
is that actually, this is a
Groovy function using some Java
libraries, but also Ascii
doctor j, which is actually
a ruby library, which is
interpreted with the J
ruby alternative JVM language.
So you have basically
three languages.
Java, Groovy, Ruby at
the same time running
with Cloud Functions for Java.
So let's continue on
this polyglot journey
with another language here.
Again, that's the same
thing, but this time, we're
using the Kotlin
programming language.
That's pretty similar.
You have to implement the
http function interface, use
the http request
and response object.
That's pretty much
the same thing,
except, of course, that
the syntax of the language
is slightly different.
Alternative languages.
Check.
But you're not locked to the
function's framework API.
It's also possible to use
familiar frameworks like Spring
Cloud, Micronaut, Quarkus,
using their own programming
models to create
functions for the Java 11
runtime for Cloud Functions.
So let's have a look.
Spring Cloud and Spring Boot
have a different approach
to creating functions.
In Spring, a function
is a Spring [INAUDIBLE]
that returns Java
function interface, which
is parameterized by an
input type and output type.
Your Spring functions returns
a lambda expression, hence
the arrow that you see
here, this example.
But you don't use the Functions
framework API directly.
You use Spring's
programming model instead.
In other framework,
this time, Micronaut.
For http functions,
the Micronaut framework
actually uses its own annotation
driven programming model.
So you can see here, we
are defining a controller,
a path, path variables, et
cetera, reusing the annotations
provided by the
Micronaut framework.
This is really just a
plain Micronaut controller.
But the Micronaut team provided
a specific Cloud Functions
integration that wraps the
Functions framework interfaces.
So Micronaut
developers just prefer
normal a plain, usual
Micronaut controller
using their programming
model that they are used to,
which is pretty poor table.
Because this controller can
run elsewhere in a container,
as a web application, and
not just as a Cloud Function.
Let's have a look at
a concrete example
with the Micronaut's framework.
So what does a Micronaut
function look like?
I'm actually going
to use a project
called Micronaut
Launch, which has
been created by the
Micronaut team to scaffold
a new project, a template
for your project.
So you can select what
you want to create,
which language you want
to use, which build,
which kind of testing tool.
And you can also add features.
So I already added it initially.
There's a specific feature
for Google Cloud Function.
So the Micronaut team
created an integration
for Cloud Functions Java 11.
So you can click the Generate
button to generate an archive
zip file for your project.
But you can also click
the little Preview
button to see what's generated.
A controller.
There's even a
Docker file if you
run that, if you want
to run that function,
that application, that
Micronaut application elsewhere,
for example, as a
Cloud Run container.
That's possible.
And there's also a build.
But I've already
downloaded this.
And, so I have a build.gradle
file that's been generated
using the function's
framework API, the invoker--
that's what allows you to run
functions locally or invoke
your functions anywhere.
And what's interesting
is that there's
a special task that's
been added here,
Run Function, which does the
same job as the Maven function
plug in, which is
using the invoker
to run the function locally.
And it's going to call the
integration point created
by the Micronaut folks,
the http function, which
is going to delegate the
work to the Halo controller.
So this controller, it's a
standard Micronaut controller,
using the Add
Controller annotation,
looking at the /halo sub path.
It's going to output
some plaintext.
Let's write something.
GCF Java 11 rocks.
Let's save this.
And then let's run that locally.
So it's going to build this
function locally and run
it locally using the
functions invoker
through the Gradle build.
So let's have a look.
Yeah.
GCF Java 11 rocks.
So, unlike Spring
Cloud and Micronaut,
Quarkus follows the function
framework native API approach,
just decorating functions with
Quarkus specific annotations,
like @Named,
@ApplicationScoped, or @Inject
to do dependency injection
for the dependencies that
are needed for your function.
This is also the same approach
for background functions.
So taking advantage of
Quarkus annotations,
but following the
Functions framework
API using the
Functions framework API
interfaces instead.
So that's about it.
I'll let Eamonn conclude.
EAMONN MCMANUS: So, we saw
a rapid tour of GCF Java.
So Java is one of the new
runtimes available with GCF
now.
We saw that there are two kinds
of functions, http functions
and background functions.
Both functions are
portable, thanks
to the Functions framework.
So you can deploy them using
the Functions framework
in production to GCF.
But you can also
run them locally.
And you can put
them in a container
and deploy them
anywhere you want.
We saw all of that it isn't
really just a Java runtime.
It's the JVM runtime.
So you can run any JVM language,
such as Kotlin or Groovy.
And finally, we saw that it
works not only on its own,
but also in conjunction
with a certain number
of other frameworks, so such
as Spring Cloud, Quarkus,
and Micronaut.
So that's GCF Java.
And we're excited to see
what you build with it.